Oh my gosh, you guys.
Sorry if my intro, or rather my loading screen, is getting longer.
I just love this song so much.
I always want to listen to it.
I'm just jamming to it.
It's so fun.
I want to post it on my YouTube.
Wait, my channel?
That sounded so weird.
I want to post it, but I have to ask Mitsukiyo's permission first.
I want to ask if it's okay.
Welcome back, master and princess.
One second.
I forgot to turn on my fan.
Welcome back.
Oh my gosh, it's been a minute since I've played Astro Bot.
If you...
What's the word?
Haven't watched me play Astro Bot.
That's okay.
There's no story.
So, you can jump in.
What's kind of nice about this game is you can jump in and see anything with this kind of game.
Yeah, we just kind of crashed and we're putting together a PS5.
Just collect the bots.
We have a whole bot army.
She's an Astro Bot.
Astro Bot.
Yeah, the story is fix your PS5.
The story is don't you want a PS5?
Don't you want a PS5?
Don't you want one so that you can play or something?
Oh, I think also this is the first time the game chat CSS is being used.
As you can see, I have a more simplified version of chat so it doesn't take up so much space for games and stuff.
So, yeah.
Hi Mint.
Hello.
Hello, hello, hello.
Cozy chat.
Small screen.
Yeah, but I love this.
It says... My head is kind of blocking it.
Oh there.
Game progress 41%.
I don't know how long I'm going to play today.
I might get really into it.
I don't know.
I kind of want to beat the game so I can move on to other games, but I'm enjoying it so much.
It's also been so long since I've started it.
I'm like, I should get finished with it soon.
Paul, thank you.
Missed your karaoke in the debut just in time for Astro Bot.
Yes.
12 hour Astro Bot endurance incoming?
Maybe.
I don't know.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Let's just start it.
Astro Bot.
Oh.
I wanted to say something.
Oh, it was about the Little Big Planet.
I've never played that series.
I thought it was so ugly.
But you bet your dollar I bought all the Metal Gear DLC for it.
Still trying to get used to your mochi mochi face.
My face is so mochi mochi.
Oh.
Oh my gosh, we're filled with monkeys.
I thought that was Raiden for a second in the middle, but it's just... I think it's Castlevania.
I'm so round.
I know, I told you guys.
I was gonna become... My face, I was gonna become round.
I told you.
Bot.
I
am Astro Bot.
Astro Bot.
I am Astro Bot.
I am
Astro Bot.
I am Astro Bot.
Hotdog gotcha, sorry.
I don't think you got it, right Mac?
Cool.
Any button.
Okay.
Save.
There you go.
We're at 150 out of 300.
We're halfway there, you guys.
And we have two... two more universes to go through.
Did we finish everything here?
Why is the snake universe calling for us?
Serpent Starlight.
Hi Minto.
Before you were talking about how people were already drawing you with pointy ears before knowing anything.
Some of us had this headcanon where your ears get pointy when you're hor...
What?
And you're Minto.
Have fun with that.
What do you mean have... How are you just gonna throw that information at me?
We?
Some people are like, I'm not included in this... in this... in this headcanon.
Who's we?
Did I miss a page in the lore?
I think I also missed a page in the lore.
It's not... Is that not why your ears are perma-pointy now?
I don't know.
Anyway...
Let's go say hi to our bots real quick.
Let's go say... Let's go... It's been a while since we've seen them.
Where is he?
Where are you?
Snake!
Naked snake.
Come here.
I like to bully them.
We have to get his... We have to get his little capsule.
We have to get his capsule.
All of our guys...
All of our guys are cat.
Cute, cute.
All of our normal guys... Woah, what's going on here?
Oh, they're building.
This is our PS5.
Oh, that's me.
Oh, it's like, why am I dressed up like this?
I forgot we got an outfit.
We have like clothes and stuff now.
Top 10 bulliable babies.
10 Snake, 9 Minto.
I kind of want to be...
How do I change?
Oh gosh.
How do I play this game again?
Oh, here we go.
I kind of want to change outfits.
Maybe do we want to be Bloodborne?
Mr. Bloodborne... John Bloodborne.
John Bloodborne?
Alright, we'll be John Bloodborne today.
Wow, we look so dapper.
Alright, let's go.
How much money do I have?
Let's see.
Let's see how much money I have for gacha.
Okay guys, we gotta go make some big bucks, okay?
We gotta go make the big dollars.
I meant to send this during the 3.0 stream, but this little wisp is super proud of you and all your work.
Thanks Joshua!
Thank you.
Here I go.
Everybody say goodbye to me.
Bye!
Bloodborne when?
Oh yeah, I gotta...
I gotta... There are so many games I gotta play, right?
Oh, we're here.
Oh, we're doing the...
What's that game called?
What is this?
Uncharted!
Yeah, yeah.
Don't mind me, I'm just here to see Johnny's combat.
Yes, he's there.
Uncharted World Time.
Dude writing.
Thank you!
Oh, no airplane!
Monkey business.
Can we die in here?
Okay guys, I learned.
I learned.
Can I beat this up?
Oh, sorry monkey.
We have a treasure map even here.
Hello.
Oh no!
Hey, where is my outfit?
We got a gun?
We have a gun?
I'm Johnny's combat.
Wait, how do I play this game again?
Shoot.
Oh, R2.
Oh, easy game.
Easy game.
The music is kind of awesome though.
Get up there!
Nothing?
Okay.
So cute and amazing with this game.
Oh my god.
That was close.
What are these?
Just little balls.
Oh, they disappear.
Oh no, they are little balls.
My balls!
No!
The music is awesome.
Is this from the game?
I wonder.
Thank you Ronin.
Oh!
There is a thing in here.
It's a remix of the soundtrack.
What
the?
Who shot me?
Okay.
I think someone up there did.
Oh, the balls are for me.
I'm shooting the balls.
Close.
I think we are good.
So sad.
I see him up there.
Let's go rescue our friend.
Skeleton too scary!
This is so fun.
Oh my gosh.
Shoot him!
Oh my god.
I like how he literally is so smug after every kill.
There is this cutie in the bottom right corner of my screen.
John Uncharted.
This guy is gone where no guy has gone before.
Is this accurate to the game?
He does this?
Really?
I wanna appear.
We really took him out.
Wait.
Oh, I have to... How do I pull again?
Like this?
There we go.
Destroy!
Kick your ass!
Looting virtuoso.
Knows you love to see her leave.
Show me the assets.
Nathan Drake is a charming MF-er.
He's a mint Vandermeer?
I didn't know he was chill like that.
Wow, look at the little dragon.
It's so cute.
Totally.
Oh gosh, ok.
Alexander, thanks for the prank.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm trying to remember how to play this game.
We're gonna go this way.
Oh...
Give me the money.
Alright, alright.
Nice.
And now we go this...
This...
Wait!
That was close.
Ok, easy.
This game is making me walk the plank.
Oh my god.
Who's yelling?
Who's laughing?
How's the music by the way guys?
Is it loud?
It feels a little...
It feels a little loud for me, but it's ok for you guys.
It's good?
Oh my god.
Thank you guys.
I'll do...
I might be somewhat of a genius.
You can turn it down a tad if you want.
Maybe like that.
It's hard for me to hear myself talk.
Is that... still ok?
Is it too... I can't tell if it's too quiet now.
Is it better?
Ok.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Monkey?
Shoot.
Oh gosh, there are so many deads here.
What the hell?
Oh my god.
I got booby trapped!
Did we get Raiden last time?
We did not.
I have not gotten Raiden yet.
There's a ladder.
I see it.
Wait, this area has so much going on.
Where do I go from...
From this...
And then there's a ladder down here.
Ok, hold on.
Let's check out the ladder first.
Down here.
Oh, it's another one of these.
Oh, but I didn't see a face.
Did you guys?
Which face is it?
I didn't see a face to match it to.
Minto would fall for a booby trap.
Just call me Freerun, ok?
You have to explore every chest.
Or else... What's the point?
Let's see.
Maybe it's a... I guess we just try all of them.
Oh wait.
Ok, no.
Hard eyes?
Angry eyes?
Tired eyes?
Aha!
What does that mean?
Bug.
Mysterious.
No force like a brute force.
Ah!
Guys, I wonder which one it was.
What is this direction though?
I can't tell.
Maybe up?
But then there is also...
Surely they don't want me to use the rope to go up there.
Right, I can't tell.
And then there is the rope that direction.
I'm so confused where to go.
Alright, hold on.
Oh,
please let me look the other direction.
No, camera!
Ok, we are not done over here yet.
Maybe I have to go from this way.
Ok, hold on.
From here...
Not a trap.
Just some flowers.
Let's grab this guy.
Oh my gosh.
Get him!
Can you do a Mito beam?
Like that?
Sully, is this guy's name?
Thousand years old, dorky elf, ghost?
Loves gacha?
Sounds like free rent to me.
Mustachioed mentor.
Doing the best with the hand they've been dealt.
Can I get the monkey?
Dang.
No monkey for us.
He belongs in his natural habitat.
And...
Oh my god.
Where were those?
There were more though that I missed up there.
Nevermind, we are really good at this game.
No monkey.
Cute!
So cute!
Oh my gosh, he is so happy.
Was there an egg on that pillar?
How did you see that?
How do I get up there?
I think we must traverse this side.
Oh my goodness.
Oh my god.
I thought he was gonna sink us.
There is another person here.
Oh my god.
Am I about to fall off?
I need to pay attention.
Oh, she already beat these guys up.
Yeah, take them down.
No nonsense Merc.
Friend to the elephants.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Hold an egg.
My treasure.
Nice!
Yeah!
Nice, nice.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna go on the Indiana Jones ride so bad right now.
Guys, I'm so excited for the Indiana Jones game.
I can't wait.
I can't wait, I can't wait.
Strange loves lab?
I guess kind of, maybe.
Yeah, you're right actually.
I can't wait.
Uncharted itself is very indie coded.
I love indie.
I love Indiana Jones!
Oh my gosh, these explode?
Oh my god!
Kill the frog!
No way, do I have to get the egg again?
Oh no, I have to get all the coins though.
Guys, we have to get all the coins because I'm trying to get snake stuff.
And snake skins too.
How many Uncharted games are there?
How many are there?
Four main line, two spin offs.
Six.
Five counting the one on the Vita.
Someone's counting the Vita?
Someone thought of the Vita in 2024?
Oh, there's a jeep up there.
I wanna drive it.
Okay guys, we gotta be fast with our shots here.
Okay, it's only like...
Like two coins over there, okay?
So it's fine if we just, you know...
I ran right into it.
Oh my gosh!
Oh my god, that was so close.
Are you okay, turtles?
So much for being able to drive the jeep like I wanted to.
I'm so sorry.
They look so distressed.
It's so sad.
Oh my gosh, this game is freaking me out today.
Just give me the save point, please.
Can I save them?
Can I help them?
I'm so sad for them.
The little guys look so distressed.
You guys think I should go back for those...
For those coins over there?
No, don't be greedy.
Don't be greedy.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
How do we...
Don't I have to like spin this guy?
Oh my gosh.
Can't see.
Yeah, there we go.
Look at these guys.
I gotcha, Minto.
I know.
Alright.
A tenacious reporter.
More valuable than any treasure.
Is she the romance?
What?
I wasn't ready!
I wasn't ready yet.
They can't get me through here, right?
Oh wow, I can hit the things mid...
Oh my gosh.
In mid-air.
Yeah, take him down.
Take him down.
This place is like a mighty clean for Uncharted.
Is that true?
Is Uncharted a dirty, nasty place?
We're almost there to the big temple.
Bird, you have to get me out of here.
Okay.
How do I do this thing again?
Are you a geist just like me?
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh!
That was so close.
I nearly lost it.
I nearly died.
What's here?
Do I need to set these ablaze?
Do I touch this?
I'm scared.
I don't want to die.
This is so fun to run through.
What was this?
Oh, it's a rock.
Oh, nevermind.
We need to go the opposite way.
Punch punch, punch punch punch punch.
Okay.
I wonder if I spin punch it.
Punch punch punch punch...
Oh, I just need to push it.
It's so much... It's so much faster that way.
If I just push it...
Oopsie.
This looks ominous!
Why are these skulls wiggling and jiggling?
Look at all these guys.
There is something in there, that's why.
What is in here?
Oh, it's a thing.
Oh, there is also...
Puzzle piece!
Nathan Drake, toucher of things.
Oh,
I like these ones.
Because you guys can't tell, but I can feel it on my...
Oh, this one.
I can feel it on my controller.
Death to you!
They were already prisoners and I still... I killed them even more.
Oh gosh.
Walk in the plank.
OK, alright.
Forgot the PS5 controller had haptics like that.
Yeah, it feels so...
It's so... Oh my gosh.
So smooth.
What's all the way up here?
Oh, nothing.
It's so incredibly smooth.
Feels so good.
What's that?
Oh boy.
Oh gosh.
Yeah!
Oh gosh!
Wait, there was a guy behind me?
Thank you guys.
Oh my gosh, thank you guys.
How did you see that?
Actually though...
It's an actual skilly man!
Oh, we heard it.
I thought I was hearing the other guy on the other side.
False ancestor.
Nathan?
Never heard of him.
Give me all of your money!
Yeah, I thought I was hearing that guy all the way.
I guess it's kind of...
I wish I could play this game on PC though.
Oh wait, did you guys notice?
That was a...
It was a... Oh my gosh.
It was a cord that you use for your controller.
Look, look, look.
Hold on.
Just saw a clip of the Nintendo redeem thingy.
So sweet, but you know what they say.
Chat reflects the streamer.
Prodigal brother.
Treasure hunting runs in the family.
We got them all!
Oh no, it disappeared.
I was going to show you guys.
Did you see it though?
Oh gosh!
Uh oh.
Wait, now you can see it.
See, see?
You can see the end.
This part is kind of crazy.
Oh my gosh.
That was close.
What the... What?
Oh my gosh, I almost...
We gotta be...
Oof.
They die so fast.
Oh my god.
Okay, I think we are alright-ish.
Okay.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
Jump!
That was close.
Okay.
Hey!
This part is so tricky.
Oh gosh, oh gosh.
Okay.
Run, run, run, run!
Real platforming time.
Real platforming.
The water is so hilly.
What?
Are you kidding me?
I just touched the water like...
What?
I can't even get my feet wet.
What is this acid water?
The controls for the gun are a little weird.
Because if I spam it, it doesn't... It's like kind of timed almost.
So it's like...
So it's like a little...
Sometimes I can spam it, but I have to time it correctly.
In a way.
Oh my gosh.
And jump!
Oh my gosh, okay.
Jump!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, nice, nice!
Okay.
Ah!
I got stuck on the...
Oh my god.
Indiana Jones time!
Please.
Nice, nice.
We made it!
What's this?
It's a piece of my PS5 I think.
Oh, it's all wrapped up?
Oh, nevermind.
Maybe it's not...
Oh my god.
What the hell is this?
Oh, I think I need to be shooting at him.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Oh gosh.
I was too close to the top.
Okay, we got this though.
Start blasting from early on.
I don't think actually blasting does anything.
Except for this part.
Okay.
Oh, that was close.
I'm blasting, I'm blasting, I'm blasting, I'm blasting!
Oh nice.
Oh, that was close.
I'm blasting!
Dummy.
Rescue the ship part!
Wow, it's so tentacly.
Mothership's GPU accelerates, renders, processes and most importantly, sings!
Go on in.
We did it all, baby.
Nice.
The GPU.
Tentacle cutting time?
Wait, is that actually what we get to do?
I'm ready.
I'm ready to do science.
Science now, everybody.
Science.
Oh my goodness, you poor thing.
Okay.
Now I'm ready to pull...
Oh, we got our little chompers.
Chomp!
Oh my gosh, if I press the right one it does...you see that?
It does the right angle.
Chomp!
BabyCorn, thanks for the gift.
What's this?
The red one goes into the...
Red tube!
The green one goes into the...
Green tube!
The blue one goes...
Let's fit it right in there.
Blue tube!
It's RGB!
RGB!
Look at her, she's beautiful.
Square.
We just need one more?
GPU.
Oh my god, this song.
Where's Snake?
GPU.
Wait, no, where's Snake?
Oh I see!
Oh my gosh, Johnny's combat and Psycho Mantis are right next to each other.
Psycho Mantis is flossing.
I don't think that's him...either.
I see...I see Gray Fox.
Where are you?
GPU.
Oh my gosh, her family grows even larger.
So close...to elephant.
Snowy Land.
Everybody is waiting for me.
Oh my gosh.
Crash Site.
Ok, let's go check it out.
Let me turn around and slap you.
Hi Johnny's combat.
Where is Solid Snake?
Does he not love me anymore?
Look at all of them pointing.
They're so cute.
Does Solid Snake not love me anymore?
So sad.
Right?
Oh my gosh.
Ok, hold on.
I gotta get up.
Sorry, excuse me.
So sorry, excuse me.
200?
Wait, I have enough guys.
Why are you acting like that?
Or do...oh no, I have 161.
Just kidding.
So let's get back home.
Snowman.
Why is Freak Phantom 3.0 so cute?
I don't know.
Because Ayami Mama's art is so beautiful.
Thank you!
Love the performance art.
The various screens.
Also been waiting for Astro Continuation.
Me too!
Oh my goodness.
I can dig in this.
I can dig in the snow.
Oh gosh, this game is so satisfying.
That's one of my favorite things about it.
Just how satisfying it is.
Pinch your cheek?
Stop it.
No pinch, no pinch.
What do I do here?
Overlifting!
Oh my gosh, we got more guys.
OK.
Destroy!
We need 90 people here.
Gosh, there is so many.
I see that guy over there too.
What does this one do?
Oh, we are lifting up to go through there I think.
Hold on though.
I gotta get rid of these guys first.
Oh my gosh.
How do I take care of this bird?
Oh shoot.
Wait.
I don't remember.
Oh, I see his head.
Grab it.
Just for one measly guy.
One little man.
Oh, I have to lift too.
Sorry.
I have to do my part.
Oh, OK.
Oh, my depth perception is...
OK, there we go.
Beautifully done.
Hi Mint.
Hello!
This area is huge.
Cute!
It's the controller cord again.
No, I haven't gotten Raiden yet.
I have not gotten Raiden yet.
Oh, where did you guys come from?
How did they do that?
Yippee!
Now we can go to another galaxy.
Oh, I guess we are going... Wait!
No, I didn't...
I don't want to go right now.
I wanted to... I opened up that other thing and I forgot to do it.
What galaxy are we opening up?
It's the Chameleon!
Lizard.
The Lizard Galaxy.
But before we go there...
Accidental progress.
Lizard Galaxy is fine.
This whole game is fine.
Where is the ice world?
There.
OK.
And we gotta do gacha.
You guys, once we get these guys over here, we'll do the gacha, OK?
Excuse me!
I wish to climb upon some men.
Oh my god.
It's all normies.
It's all little normie guys.
What parts did we not get?
Oh!
There is a guy right here.
I completely missed him.
He was just chilling here.
Thank you!
Nice.
I just never got that guy.
And we need to do this one.
I need 100 men to help me.
Group effort.
And I need 90 more men to help me once again.
I'm doing my part.
Oh!
What the hell?
How does this work?
How do I not lose the momentum?
Wait.
How do I not lose the momentum here?
Huh?
Reajuu bakuhatsu shiro.
Hold right when jumping?
I do try.
I do try though.
I'm even holding up even to like...
Don't double.
I wasn't...
I'm not double jumping.
Maybe from this... From this side?
Just right.
Yeah, that's what I'm doing.
Oh wait.
There we go.
We're good.
We got it.
I can't see anything.
Magical egg.
A flower.
Restorative flora.
Carries nature's healing touch.
I got a flower.
Destroy.
Oh, the penguins hold money.
See, this is why you destroy everything, you guys.
Is there anything else?
There you go.
You see that egg up there?
And we got this.
And I need 80 guys for...
Oh my gosh.
Crash Bandicoot scared me.
What the...
Did you see all of them?
Easy now.
Wow.
Easy, easy.
We got this.
Slow and steady.
Come on.
Oh my god, the bird is holding on to him.
Easy, easy.
Good pace.
We're OK.
Everything is fine.
OK Oh my gosh!
Stop.
Is this Tokyo Jungle?
Stop it right now!
You guys!
Urban Survivors think it's a Tokyo Jungle dog!
Oh my gosh!
The cutest little predator!
Oh my god!
That's so fun!
I didn't know that they would be in this game too!
Oh my gosh!
That's so fun!
Alright, we're gonna have to come back for this 200 here.
Whatever it does.
I feel like we've gotten everything here, but...
Clearly not.
I love Tokyo Jungle.
Need to play Tokyo Jungle.
It's so fun.
Such a good game.
Let's grab some more money before we...
And...
Where is the other guy?
Grab some more money.
And gotcha time.
You can check the map too here.
There are some golds in here.
Crush!
Chartered territory.
There be treasure.
Snake.
Pirate outfit.
Colorful dice.
Oh cute!
Snake.
Hold on.
All sorts of creatures.
Even snakes!
I see you in there.
I want his outfit too though.
Is this a color for our ship?
Neon dream.
Wow!
It's really pretty.
I like this one.
One more.
Outfit.
Gran Turismo!
Awesome.
Good haul this time guys.
Nice.
Let's go change this.
Wait, do we have almost all the...
All the colors?
Is this the one we just got?
Yeah, I love this one.
John Turismo.
Nice.
Go see snake, of course.
We also must change.
No more Bloodborne, sorry.
I'm now...
John Turismo.
Let's go.
It's so cute!
Why do I look so chubby?
I feel like I look chubbier than usual.
Than in the other outfits.
I don't know why it looks so puffy in this one.
It's the helmet?
It must be, right?
Oh my gosh.
What an area.
It's his...
Stop it!
Oh my gosh, the banana!
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh!
I'm so happy!
Oh my gosh.
This one is so silly.
He's like, no, don't eat my food.
This one is my favorite though.
Of course, a croc.
Look at his little crawl!
It's so good.
So good, I love a croc hat.
Oh wait, this isn't...
Where is...
Is this?
No, that's not the flower we got.
Where is Tokyo Jungle Dog?
I wonder.
I want to get pyramid heads too.
He's following me!
Our little island is so...
Our little island is so active now.
He recovers so well.
He does the same thing as Snake.
Yeah, it's so lively.
Where is...
Where is...Oh there he is!
Are you going to do anything?
Oh he also follows me!
Pressing down next to Crash?
What do you mean pressing down?
Where is Crash?
Like Crash Bandicoot?
Where is that guy?
Oh, there is Spyro.
Crash.
Oh there he is.
Our area is so lively.
There is a lot that I haven't checked out yet.
Oh my gosh!
So cute!
Creepy!
Was
that a look card?
I'm pretty sure it was.
The Sushi.
You deserve all the success.
Thank you!
Alright.
New galaxy time?
Either Alucard or Cain.
Oh it's Cain from Legacy of Cain.
There was Alucard though, wasn't there?
Is Raiden in this one?
Wasn't he?
This one?
I think?
What's this one?
Rolling Star Luna?
Let's try diving in here.
Real quick.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Ouch!
OK, don't double jump everybody.
No double jump.
So fast!
It's so fast!
OK, maybe I don't go for the coins.
Don't be greedy maybe.
Oh gosh!
It's so fast!
My guy came back!
How the hell?
Nice.
OK.
Gotta jump fast.
Can I jump with this guy on though?
Oh yes, OK, OK.
Oh my gosh.
OK, OK.
The music in this is so...
Look at those little dragons!
At the sleepy moon.
This is such a cute level.
I'm appreciating it a little bit real quick.
Look at the way they are running.
OK, I gotta jump fast.
Oh gosh!
How do I do this one?
We gotta be balanced.
Oh gosh.
OK, I might take it slow and steady perhaps.
Oh my god.
OK, OK.
Monkey ball, kind of, maybe.
Oh my gosh.
No, no!
I know we can do this one.
It's just... Oh my gosh.
It's just maybe a little bit of patience, I think.
Maybe if I launch, if I kick the...
If I kick the armadillo...
At him, we should be OK.
I think.
If I kick it at him...
And then run and be careful, you know?
OK.
Like that.
Oh gosh, it spooks me though.
Like this, right?
You think I can kick him from here?
No, not far enough.
Come here, guy!
Will he follow?
Yeah, he does.
That was so close!
Holy moly!
Oh gosh, it's slowly but surely turning.
Wait, come back to me.
We are safe on here, so...
Oh gosh.
OK, OK.
Nice, nice.
Alright, alright, alright.
I scared him!
We got him!
He's Streetwise Cat!
A kitty of many vices.
Isn't this the other cat from...
I got the other guy.
I can't remember, I'm sorry.
Yeah, we did it!
That's not Raiden.
No way!
Are you sure?
Are you sure that's not Raiden?
There's a bunch of other ones actually in here.
What's this one?
What is this?
Swinging Sentries?
Is Raiden the last...
The last...
Metal Gear in this game?
Who the hell are you?
Congrats on the 3.0!
I had to catch the re-debut VOD, but I loved it.
Thank you, Nevermore!
No worries about even watching the VOD.
OK, this one's Raiden.
Guys, this one is really hard though.
This is really hard though.
I don't quite remember how to do it, even.
Oh gosh, OK.
OK.
Alright.
OK, OK.
I remember this last part was the one that caused me the most trouble.
I think I just have to swing and...
Oh, it was like I just have to swing and...
Like, I can't even... I can't delay.
I have to just swing and jump and...
Swing and jump immediately.
It's the part that causes me... Yeah, I gotta go really fast.
Oh.
Oh god.
We got here.
First try.
OK.
I haven't been able to get past this part.
I'm scared.
Yeah.
I got killed by the easiest freaking enemy.
No.
I got killed by the easiest freaking guy.
That's so embarrassing.
I'm so sorry, guys.
Oh my goodness.
Oh.
OK.
I did get that first try though.
Isn't that kind of crazy?
Shoot the...
I tried jumping again, but it wouldn't let me.
It wouldn't let me.
Nice shoot.
Oh.
Gosh, that was so close.
We can do it.
Nice.
OK.
There we go.
I wish there was a save point here.
I wish there was a save point.
What is going... OK, hold on.
OK, so I jump onto that platform moving...
And then I somehow get to that guy moving too...
And then I jump, and then I jump, and then I...
There's spikes and other guys flying...
And then, the end, at the very end...
What is he doing?
Oh, he's...
He's playing on...
Is that PSP or Vita?
OK.
Alright.
You mastered the hard part.
I don't know if that was the hard part.
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
It goes so fast.
How am I supposed to...
Get there?
I want... Oh, that was so...
Close.
Oh gosh.
What?
Guys...
I don't know if I have the patience for this right now.
But we must get Raiden.
I said I would get him today.
That was so...
Dirty.
Of you...
Oh my goodness.
Poor Raiden is never getting saved.
No!
I'll save him.
I'll do it.
OK.
Next round.
That was...
Close.
I double jumped.
I did.
Holy moly.
Reflexes of steel, baby.
Oh my god.
Save him and then slap him.
Why does he have the hardest level?
This guy.
This hecking guy.
Some of these challenge levels are...
Some of these challenge levels are no joke for real.
Is it possible to grab him before the end of the map?
I don't think so.
They wouldn't make it like that.
OK.
Oh my gosh.
This one is so tricky.
Raiden!
Why do I have to love you so much?
Oh my god.
OK.
We made it to here.
Yippee!
OK.
We made it to here.
This part is really...
Wow-y though.
Oh gosh.
OK.
I think it's because I'm like scared of him shooting at me, you know?
What are you doing with that mem...
He's blowing into the memory card!
No!
You're not supposed to do that!
OK.
Flame!
Thanks for the ping!
You can do it.
No checkpoints now.
There's no checkpoints in these.
Because they're pretty short.
It's just you gotta be good.
Oh my god.
It
doesn't recognize my double jump sometimes.
I'm just gonna stick with this one.
OK.
This might be my last try for now.
Holy moly.
I hate that part.
I hate it.
I hate these guys!
I hate them!
I wish them all a very horrible night!
I hope...
I hope they suffer forever!
Oh my god.
Oh gosh.
I registered it.
Oh my gosh.
Suffer little slime blobs!
No!
Suffer slime blobs.
Slime blobs!
I'm gonna take my frustrations out on this plant.
Oh gosh.
I guess she doesn't...
What do you mean?
I'm trying.
I've been at this for like an hour.
Oh gosh.
It moves so fast.
It moves so fast and he spits...
He spits so deadly!
Oh gosh.
OK.
We're like 15 minutes.
Wait, it's only been 10 minutes?
No, it hasn't.
It's been way longer than 10 minutes, right?
It's been about 15... Wait, now people are saying 20 minutes.
20... Wait, now it says 25 minutes!
You guys are just like those...
When you go to a theme park and it's like estimated 20 minutes...
And then it's like 45 minutes later and you're like...
We believe in you.
Don
Teresimo, wake up!
He is freaking dead.
Oh, that's a shadow.
He died of old age.
He... He truly is the end.
Oh gosh, you guys, I have no...
I have no confidence in this part!
Confidence!
I have no confidence!
Come to me!
You gotta change to the pirate outfit.
No!
Oh, look at us.
We're wobbling.
Oh!
I gotta go to the bathroom.
I'm back.
But I don't wanna be!
Yeah, I was an angry pee.
I don't wanna be back.
I'm so tired.
I'm so tired of this whole freaking round!
Screw you!
Little blob!
I can't believe I survived all of what the chameleon was throwing at me.
Just for... Just for me to die falling off the edge!
It's too cruel!
This game is too cruel!
The satisfaction when you win though...
We'll hope... We'll hope for a win, man.
This is the real... Oh my gosh.
This is like the real...
This is the real good hours of this game, man.
Okay, we're back.
We're back here.
We got here pretty quickly actually.
Hold on, let me drink some water.
I've been trying to drink a lot more water recently because...
And like less... Not that I drink a ton of caffeine.
But I'm trying to drink more water because I... Recently I've been getting like...
I don't know if it's like just from staring at the computer screen too much, but...
Like a lot of headaches behind my eyes.
So...
No, not with Auras, no.
I've never had an Auras...
Headache before.
No, I don't think it's caffeine withdrawal.
I don't know though.
I've been just trying to drink a lot of water.
I think it might be...
It might be just staring at a computer screen for so long.
There's a reason this BGM is called Perseverance.
Ganbamito, thank you.
Might be the change of seasons.
Oh, maybe, that too.
Peanut butter withdrawal.
Peanut butter.
That was so close.
Oh, that was so close!
Kill him!
Kill him dead!
Okay.
We killed him dead.
Oh my gosh!
Yes!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, we're so close!
He's right there!
Please, god, please!
Please!
Oh please, please!
Mountain buster!
Nanomachine inside!
Raiden, welcome home!
I'll match you.
I'll match you, kind of.
It looks funky with my sunglasses on though.
Oh my gosh, and this is supposed to be November.
November?
Ducky, thanks for the 10 gifts!
Oh my gosh!
Never doubt it.
Thanks for the pink, Octo!
Let's go see him.
Oh, Mappy!
Thanks for the pink!
Mintos stream on my birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, Mappy Rose!
Happy birthday!
Thank you!
Sirstreak, thanks for the 5 gifted.
I can relax.
Oh my god, there he is!
Oh, he's with all of them!
Oh my god, I'm gonna cry!
No, they're so cute!
I think his gacha will probably be...
I was gonna say his sword, but it probably is...
It's probably Sam's sword.
How much money did I even get from that anyway?
Probably not a lot.
Yeah, I don't even have enough.
Get me out of here.
I don't even have enough to do a single pull.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god, I'm so out of breath from that.
We can finally continue the game.
I never want to do another challenge level ever.
I'm so tired.
Wait, how much is left in this?
We missed a puzzle piece?
Where?
We've got all the puzzle pieces here.
We just missed some challenge guys I think there.
Oh, and even in the gorilla!
Oh my gosh.
Well, I never intended on 100%ing this game, so...
It's okay if I do or don't, you know, whatever.
Cool.
No!
They're playing cat...
Don't bully him!
You nasty alien, you!
We got the metal gears.
I think that's the most important.
Probably.
Watermelon.
Our ship is gone.
Don't do it.
I'm sick of you guys.
I'm so...
I'm so sick of you.
Your nastiness.
I'm sick of you blowing at me.
I'm sick of it.
I'm tired of it.
Oh my god, where the hell are you guys?
Oh, they're on me!
Oh shoot!
Hold on!
There we go.
That was close.
Oh my gosh.
I forgot about those guys.
I'm still out of breath.
I'm still so out of breath, man.
I'm still like reeling from...
I'm still reeling from the...
I'm like, my mind is empty.
It's a pulse ride in clarity, maybe.
There's more.
It was intense.
It was.
I'm so glad that we could defeat it.
Thanks guys for not giving up.
For believing in me.
Oh!
Leah!
Welcome to Mambo Show!
Stop!
What the heck?
Leah is one who helped with my lore video.
Thank you!
Nice.
Just before he could regenerate.
I heard a guy though, I'm pretty sure.
Oh my goodness.
Oh shoot!
Holy moly.
How the heck am I supposed to...
I thought I heard a guy.
Maybe I'm wrong.
I
think I figured it out.
Buzzsaw guy goes hard.
For real!
Oh, I got him.
I don't know what I did, but I did it.
I thought I heard a guy.
Welcome to the team, little bot.
I feel like soon we're gonna have enough to...
Oh, no, I wanted to... Wait, hold on.
You too.
Soon we're gonna have enough to be able to do that...
What's the word?
The one that required 200 bots.
Oh my god.
Evil.
Evil game.
This game is so evil sometimes.
Nice.
I knew that was gonna happen.
It's okay.
200 thing.
Yeah, whatever it was in that snowy area.
Nice.
Oh, there's a lot of save checkpoints here in this area though.
It's actually quite...
Quite nice.
Only the challenge levels are so evil.
But the game itself is not so mean.
Hmm...
Checking for any hiddens.
If I miss anything, just yell at me, okay?
Just say... I see, I hear one.
I hear a guy going...
Where are you?
Show yourself!
I keep it funky.
Oh my god.
He keeps it funky.
Yeah.
Keeps it funky.
He made me above.
True.
Oh my goodness!
Is that who I... Wait, did my...
My big head might have...
My big head might have hidden who that was, I think.
Hmm...
Sneaky.
Oh my gosh.
Sexy maiden.
Missing Lara Croft!
Hot dog, indeed!
Righty, thank you!
Congrats on getting right in.
That was some real perseverance.
Yeah!
Hot dog, indeed, baby!
Aristocratic archaeologist.
A Brit of an icon.
Look at her!
Uh-oh.
We're sneaky.
That's so fun.
Oh, now I have to jump off.
Oh, okay, interesting.
I'm greedy.
It's okay.
Oh, nice.
That was a close one.
I keep it funky.
I keep it funky funky.
I keep it funky Friday.
Freaky funky funky.
I keep it so funky.
What's this?
What is this?
I hear a guy crying!
I hear... Oh, he's up there!
How do I...?
Gotta get the power-up first.
Oh, I see, I see.
Is it here?
Power-up!
Oh, I guess the power-up is over there.
Nevermind.
Money.
Oh my gosh, this is so satisfying.
Oh my gosh, look at this.
Oh god, this game.
I feel like this is gonna ruin my bit right now.
Sorry to the stream.
Okay, let's let him out.
We got our big boy panties on now.
Oh no.
What is this?
Oh god!
Why?
Get out of here.
Oh, and it helps us get into small spaces too.
Interesting indeed.
What's here?
Nothing, I guess.
It kinda looks like a spot though, doesn't it?
I'm a little ball.
Oh!
Fujisan, my beloved!
And now we can go in here.
I noticed this earlier.
I was like, oh, it's a little way.
Guys, I think I'm a genius.
I freed you, snake!
I just saw this version of you.
It looks fantastic.
Thank you!
Sure is not Chilean volcano.
I'm pretty sure it's Fujisan.
No!
Take me back!
I didn't get the guy over there.
Oh, there's a ladder here.
You guys, coming back was a good thing.
Money, baby!
Actually, nevermind.
The WFC music!
Welcome to Babushan!
Thank you!
Thank you.
I'm glad you like the new look.
Guys, I think I screamed a little much.
A little too much.
What is this doing?
Where is this guy?
This game is so nice, isn't it?
I don't understand this power-up.
I think I screamed too much a little bit earlier.
Now my throat hurts.
This game really does think of a lot of stuff like that bird there.
It'll be like, oh yeah, you probably wanted to go back if you missed that.
I'll give you a little shortcut.
It's actually so nice.
What the hell is that thing though?
I think
I know what to do.
Come here.
Suck me up, baby.
This is so fun!
Evil vacuum.
Mothman.
Nice.
OK.
Oh, these guys?
No, no, no.
Wait, how do I be sneaky through here?
Oh, just like this?
I'm like invincible with this guy, basically.
Oh my god.
Are you OK?
Oh no!
Third and final puzzle piece.
Click, click, click.
I don't like pants, Mothman.
I think I'm a genius, you guys.
Nice.
Who's here?
Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh.
Kick him!
Kick him while he's down!
Holy, how did I... Oh my gosh!
Oh shoot.
Oh my god, that was so close.
How did I survive that?
Good!
Nice.
Checkpoint?
Oh my god.
Punch him, punch him.
Punch him, punch him, punch.
Punch him, punch him, punch, punch.
Why is he acting so sussy like that?
What's wrong with you?
Oh, I can decide which way I want to go.
Oh.
No!
Wait, is there something in every direction?
What?
Rescue...
We missed one.
We missed one!
Oh shucks.
What did we miss?
Where at?
This way maybe?
He only shoots in three ways.
So I think I have to go back.
Or not.
Or there is no way to go back.
Over yonder?
Where though?
I never heard another guise.
Wait a second.
Oh I see it!
All the way!
I see it.
Oh, there is a ladder.
You guys see the glowing over there?
Ah, I see it.
I don't think it will be so hard to...
Get back there actually.
We can just take the bird.
Take the bird...
Up to here.
Oh, where is he taking me?
No, bird!
You were supposed to take me over there!
Bird!
Bird, no!
Now I do have to go through all of this again.
Oh my god.
We do have to go through all of this again.
Oh, that was close.
Oh, there is another bird.
I don't trust you bird.
I don't trust you other bird.
Oh, that was so close.
Oh my gosh.
I almost didn't ball.
We are balling, we are balling.
Right here.
Let's take the ladder.
Alright, which one is it?
You!
Oh gosh.
Well, at least we got more money.
That was so sneaky.
Sneaky little bot.
Okay.
Let's take the bird back.
To the golf course.
It's probably easier.
Bird, now you are to prove of your use.
Yes, I did not understand your usefulness before, but now I appreciate it.
Thank you.
And... Thank you, thank you, thank you.
And I'm in.
Oh
my goodness.
Can you come down here?
Nice.
There.
Easy peasy.
Lemon squeezy.
I almost... I think I messed that up.
A mystery.
What the hell?
Secret.
Pineapples!
What are you doing with all those pineapples?
And a person!
Who is that?
Secret.
What are you supposed to do here?
Pineapples!
Okay, we got rid of some pineapples.
I'm just...
Oh my gosh.
Is it Ada?
Ada Wong?
I don't think so.
I can't tell... Is it?
I can't tell who that is.
You shall see, if I ever get them down.
Alright, come here.
There we go.
Who is that?
Wait, I recognize... Oh, I don't remember the...
I have a whopping 107 friends.
Oh, what is this game?
Suikoden!
Oh my gosh, I really... I really messed up my throat earlier.
This is what Raiden does to me.
Raiden, you jerk!
Raiden, you made me mess up my throat!
I'm just gonna blame him.
Raiden, you jerk, you...
Big dummy jerk, Raiden.
I think we got everything, but there's a warp here and I didn't see it.
I didn't see a warp.
Like a place to find a warp, even.
Mysterious.
What?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh my goodness.
I guess this is not the end.
First try, let's go.
We showered with riches!
Nice.
My reaction time for that was pretty good, I'm not gonna lie.
Unless the warp is over there.
Warp over there.
Warp could be anywhere.
We're overflowing with riches, oh my gosh.
Riches beyond our wildest imagination.
Oh my gosh, you guys are so rich.
We're rich in friendship.
Hey warp, you around here?
I can't tell, where am I?
Oh my god.
Oh wait.
This one.
What's happening?
Oh gosh.
This one.
Oh goodness.
Oh this one.
Oh.
We made it!
Money.
Money is our motivation.
Is this the warp?
Oh yeah it is.
There we go.
I did find it after all.
Oh gosh, I'm gonna get a cough drop.
Stupid Raiden.
You jerk.
I say as I'm the one who screamed.
You guys, I'm almost done with my spider cookie.
I still have all the other cookies still to eat.
Motivation!
Oh my god, thank you.
Yeah, I've been slowly eating through the cookies.
Secret.
Nice.
Rocket pull power.
I guess we better dive on in.
Wait, why did we not finish here?
Oh we didn't get a puzzle piece.
This one was a lot of fun.
It's a secret.
Let's try it.
Hmm.
Kinda sounds like they are saying made in man.
They love me.
What's this?
We got a chicken!
What's the chicken power again?
That's the chicken power.
Oh my god, it's so cute that you can knock all the snow off the trees though.
Sorry birdies.
Flowers.
Little seals.
Oh my gosh, this area is so beautiful it makes me want to go back to Antarctica.
Die.
You especially die.
Oh, did I kill him?
Oh gosh.
Spooked me.
How was Antarctica?
So amazing.
Oh, whoops.
I forgot to grab it.
So awesome.
Oh, I did it again.
I love when these guys sound like they are saying kikiriki.
Not sure if you get many northern lights in Antarctica.
There's the southern lights, but...
Wait, what's here?
Wait, was there anything?
I don't think so.
There's the southern lights, which I really wanted to see.
But, unfortunately, did not happen while we were there.
Oh my gosh, the wolves!
The sniper wolves are in my way!
No swimming.
What?
Who is this?
Magical graffitist.
Their drawings really come to life.
Oh no, your voice.
I screamed way too much, oh gosh.
I was so angry.
I messed up, you guys.
I did the one thing a streamer shouldn't do.
Get angry.
Picture!
So cute.
Beautiful.
I'll be better tomorrow.
What's in here?
Oh goodness.
Nice.
Okay, no swimming.
Okay.
Oops.
Is the puzzle piece still here or did I already get it?
Oh, it counts for lots of coins.
So that's good.
One of the squirrels fell in.
There we go.
Alright.
Let's make sure I'm not missing anything.
Missing...
Oh my god, I almost said missing.
Missing anything over the sides as well.
Since there's two puzzle pieces we gotta be on the lookout for.
How do I do this one?
Gosh.
Give me all the money.
I think we're good.
There
we go.
Nice.
Just don't get frozen.
Yeah, pretty much.
Can I put my head on the cutout?
Oh, cute!
Let's see if I can...
Oh no, wait.
My mask is too big.
I can be in front of the cutout, but it doesn't have the same effect, I think.
Doesn't really have the...
Doesn't really have the same effect, I think.
Okay.
So cold.
Oh my goodness!
Nice.
Evil.
Oh goodness.
We were too cold, now we're too hot.
What do you want from me, little guy?
Oh my god.
Nasty.
Nothing over the side it seems.
What the hell is that thing?
I think it's a crab.
Give me the money.
Oh shoot, not this guy.
Come here, come here.
Mint went to hell.
Oh gosh, oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Oopsie.
Woo!
Nice.
Okay.
Now once we...
Perfect.
Good job, us.
Made pancake.
What are you trying to say, huh?
Pancake?
Is that what we're calling me now, huh?
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Evil.
I tried to get the... We have to get him.
We have to get him this way.
We have to bait him this way.
Oh my god.
Ah, shoot.
Still worked, baby.
Yeah!
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
I can't believe how many levels are in this game, honestly.
Oh, he's dead.
Nevermind.
He's alive, unfortunately.
Oh, I'm dead.
Unfortunately.
I'm the dead one.
Oh man.
Easy.
See?
See, easy?
Easy.
You were always the dead one.
True.
So true.
We need this guy.
Oh, shoot.
I don't think that worked.
Oh, grab it!
Yeah!
Goodness.
Alright, get away from my...
Sometimes this game can drive a ghost mad.
Oh, I hear you.
Who are you?
Get him in the butt.
Who is that?
Wormhole survivor.
3 billion years from home.
Who is this?
I died.
Today I discovered...
It's a pancake.
I love pancakes.
They're delicious.
I prefer...
No, waffles.
Oh, he's just a PSVR guy?
Oh, fun.
How do I get to this underneath though?
And I hear another guy.
He's like...
You hear that?
Where is he?
It's not us, is it?
How do I get in here?
Laser feet?
Oh, if I...
I see.
Just from the inside.
You're so smart.
I didn't know you were smart.
Oh gosh.
I didn't know you were so smart.
Wait, how do I kill this guy again?
I think I might have to bird...
I might have to chicken over on top of him.
Oh my gosh.
I want to kill him before we go back to get all the stuff over here, you know?
I keep forgetting to bird.
Good morning.
This game is cute.
It's cute.
Don't touch the magma.
It won't let me back up.
Oh wait, this is how I went up.
This is how I went up.
Oh god.
Was it worth it for three coins?
I don't know, but...
Oh my gosh.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Holy moly.
We still got his ass.
Yeah!
We still got his butt.
S1!
Thank you for the 20 gilded!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Is that the last guy down there?
Oh shoot.
Let's try again.
Dang it.
I almost had it.
Oh.
Uh oh.
No, not this shit again.
Are you serious?
No way.
Seriously?
Oh my god.
How am I gonna get out of here though?
Holy...
Oh my god.
We were so close!
So close!
I'm a genius.
I might be a genius.
Oh my god.
Well, I said that, but...
Living relic.
What did I get?
They'll leave you in pieces.
What is that?
What is that thing?
Here comes the money!
Give it a decade!
Knack.
Who's Knack?
Clear baby, clear.
Okay, hold on.
We can do eight more gotchas.
It's a chicken guy.
Okay, nice.
We're killing it, you guys.
We're killing it.
We haven't done a single...
Oh no, that's a lie.
We've done one world from the new universe.
I was gonna say, it's been two and a half hours...
We haven't done really anything.
Oh my gosh, they're flossing.
Oh boy.
Oh, we get whatever this elephant is.
All the animals flock to us.
Animal attraction.
The safari park is open.
That is a wild achievement.
Oh, this one is huge.
Okay, what's in here?
Safari.
Safari park!
Is this like a Pokemon?
It's bigger on the inside.
Cheese!
Emotes?
I can't...
Oh...
Okay.
Is there money in here?
That's all I care about.
I'll take that.
What's this?
I got...
Oh my god!
Knack is back, baby!
It's the little dog!
Who's a good boy?
Can I take a photo anywhere?
Oh, I can.
That's fun.
But this says it's a designated photo spot.
Okay, everybody say cheese!
Hold on.
My hand is really shaky.
Can I zoom in?
Oh, here we go.
Cheese!
Strike a pose!
You get money for the photos?
Why I don't get any money here?
Oh my god!
Where's my money?
What the hell?
This is so silly.
Where
are we going?
What's this?
We got...
Another dog!
A paw pose!
This area is huge.
My goodness.
Another photo spot there.
More money up here.
Let's go.
I didn't know they were known for...
The capybara!
Not the capybara.
I didn't know they made those little pups.
The Sony pups?
Oh my gosh, too cute.
Hold on.
Oh my gosh, so cute!
How do I emote?
Oh, it's my face!
I'm in love with the monkey.
Cute, so cute.
Where is it?
Oh, that's not an egg.
What's up here?
Snail.
What's the point of going up here?
I don't know.
Return to monkey.
How do I swim again?
Oh, there we go.
Woah.
Where is the money?
Any money in here?
I'm greedy.
Give me the money!
Ok, nevermind.
Let's go do some gacha.
Money on the tree?
That one?
I don't know how to get out there.
It's ok.
I had fun in here.
Safari zone is so fun.
We are trying for snake outfits.
Let me...
Snake outfits, let's go!
What is that?
Doomed ride.
Oh, it's the Uncharted truck.
Wait.
This is not a skin.
Or this is not clothes.
This is for...
Oh, lion.
Skin?
Oh, stop.
It's so cute.
It's a red panda.
I'll take it.
What's this one?
Couch TV game thing.
Duel Raider.
Another skin for our controller.
We can do four more.
Handy cannon.
Cute.
And...
Ineffective jail.
A reminder of Drake's misfortune.
One more...
Forty-five's boar?
Oh
my gosh!
It's the... Oh my gosh, this really is the PSVR.
That's it.
Time to be a five's boar.
Forty-five's boar.
Try not... Scariest stories.
Try not to get scared.
Forty-five's boar.
Let's become him.
Got it.
Give me money.
No!
I don't even know if there is a snake outfit, but I hope there is.
Forty-five's boar.
Oh my gosh, we're too cute actually!
Wait, what's the red panda though?
Oh my gosh, stop!
We gotta be forty-five's boar though.
Hoar!
Oh you got your thing!
The blowing the flowers is really cute.
Oops, sorry my button.
What else we got?
Turn
the things!
I understand now!
I get it!
Oh my gosh!
I get it now!
You're not gonna get any stylish points like that!
Yeah, yeah, come on!
Oh my gosh, everything here.
Sorry mister.
The kid turned into a dog.
He's got that dog in him.
He's smacking his meat.
He's beating his meat.
The bird.
What does this guy do?
Oh goodness gracious!
Which game is this one?
It reminds me of... I know it's not, but it reminds me of Knight.
Devil Dice.
Hello Mint!
Hello, hello, hello!
Let's go back to the chameleon world.
Nice!
Oh my gosh, I can't believe we golded that one.
What should we do?
Oh gosh, it's probably all underwater.
Let's go to the balloon... It sounds like a breeze.
Balloon breeze, my kind of place.
Until like 10 people on this chat knows Knight.
Well, I do too, okay?
If you know, you know.
Little beetle.
Oh that's right, I gotta beat these guys up.
Good job.
Elliebot!
Welcome to membership, thank you!
Wait, was there anything else down here?
Hey, hey, hey, you, you, you.
Hey, hey, you, you.
I need to go on your tummy.
There's a puzzle, there's a puzzle.
Over there's a puzzle, please.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Looks so delicious, this guy.
Nice.
Everything is alive in this game.
It's kind of crazy.
There's a guy!
Help me!
I got him.
Imagine being a shovel.
What's wrong?
We have to have...
We have to have jobs for everything.
You know?
There's gotta be some people who are the...
Our friend!
Some guys who are the giants that are awesome and some guys who are the...
The shovels.
Hold on a second, I'm starting to get a little bit hungry, so I'm gonna finish my sandwich here.
How are you guys doing this weekend?
My big brother.
I've always wanted a big brother.
Good and lazy.
Lazy is good on the weekend.
Got scared that today is Sunday?
I'm actually going out with some friends tomorrow.
I know.
Minto?
Leaving the maid cafe?
I'm going out with some friends tomorrow, which is why I have a really early stream.
I'm touching grass.
I'm going outside.
It's gonna be crazy, but I'm really excited.
I'm kind of nervous about the web fishing though, because all I see from people is...
Is that their games keep getting hacked or something.
So I'm like, is that gonna happen to me?
But how do I get you?
Oh my gosh, this is kind of annoying.
How do I get your eyes?
Leave me alone!
I
can't attack while I'm in the air.
How am I supposed to...
Hold on.
I've heard some VTubers complaining about getting hacked.
There we go.
I think I was overthinking it.
Yeah, so I'm a little nervous about like...
About it, but hopefully it's okay.
Oh my god, he's...
Brother.
I've always wanted a brother.
It's kind of freaking me out.
Okay, see you later brother.
Oh, what the hell?
I gotta inflate this thing.
Oh no!
Oh, it's... Okay.
Wait, how do I... Oh my god, please.
There we go.
And an Upsidaisy.
Oh, what is that?
Oh my god!
We're just inflating everybody.
What the hell?
Rainbow.
Rainbow!
Oh, money.
It pays.
Deploy.
There we go.
What flew out?
Oh, what is that?
What is it?
Oh, it gives me more air.
Wow, interesting.
Interesting.
Oh gosh, there's even more of them.
Let's wait until he shoots again.
Ice him.
Easy game, easy game.
Oh my gosh!
I can even destroy those!
That's crazy.
Oh my gosh.
The detail.
That's crazy!
What the...
Oh, brother.
Brother.
Oh my gosh, succulents.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, hello.
I'm not very happy to see you because...
We can't even go back!
We missed somebody.
We missed somebody and we can't go back.
And it was an important person.
It was a VIP.
Oh, that sucks.
That sucks.
I see you.
I see you drowning in there.
I got you!
What?
Wait, what?
I'm gonna lose my brain cells.
I'm gonna lose my...
What?
Is he in here?
What is going on here?
He is refusing your advances.
What is happening?
Are they like flirting?
What is going...
Oh my goodness.
Where did I miss?
You guys, I'm actually legitimately so confused.
Unless it's like somewhere in here.
You think like beneath the rocks there's a...
There's a...
Maybe a...
A stringpole?
I don't see one.
It's hidden in the beans.
In the beans.
Maybe over by the cacti.
I don't know.
I hear a shimmering.
I don't know what that is though.
Oh, it's coming from...
Oh, it's these guys.
Every time I get close they like open up.
See?
They open up.
I don't know why.
They are very friendly.
That's what the shimmering is.
But where is the guy if he is even in here?
Actually,
I think that's the way we need to go.
I think this is just for extra somethings or other.
Oh my gosh, I'm gonna get dead.
I'm gonna die!
Oh my gosh.
That was close.
Oh, I see one in there.
Stop harassing her!
Who are you?
Who is this?
Young holiday maker.
Still remembers the summer of...
Oh, it's that!
Isn't that Natsu something?
My summer?
My summer vacation.
I remember watching the Tim Rogers...
Actually, wait.
I think I remember seeing the Tim Rogers video.
Maybe I didn't watch it though.
Hidden money.
I remember seeing his video about it, but I didn't watch it yet.
You have to really make time for those sorts of events, right?
OK.
We got this.
Probably.
Oh, I just realized we have like a little...
Oh my goodness.
They spit at me!
Disgusting.
Oh, this guy is spitting at me.
Nevermind.
Hey, chill out.
How do I get out of this?
There we go.
Easy.
I hear somebody.
I can't believe we missed one!
I can't believe it!
So sad.
So stupid.
Oh my gosh.
Dandelion.
Oh, I gotta breathe.
Rain, rain, go away!
Oh my goodness.
Alright.
There's one more guy we gotta get.
At least.
If it was just a normal guy, that'd be one thing.
But it's a dang...
It's a dang special guy.
Special character.
Chill out, guy.
I should've...
I should've been more careful.
There's no guys here, right?
I think I should land on that little flower.
I mean that little petal.
Nah, I'll grow a knife.
No, no, no, no!
I'm gonna die.
Everybody...
Goodbye!
Okay, I got greedy.
And I died.
Nice.
Attack.
And this one over here.
Please, please come back!
Come to me!
Gosh.
The more I think I get better at this game, the more I realize I've regressed.
This one is kinda tricky though.
I'd say it's the most difficult...
Because once you start blowing out...
Once you start blowing out, you have to commit to the blowout.
It's not like a...
Oh, I'll just re-inflate.
You gotta... You blow out.
Alright.
If I just miss... If I miss...
I'm just gonna have to go with it, I think.
Okay.
We can go to the top.
Okay, we can do that.
Stop blowing at me!
Okay.
It's this one over here.
Oh my gosh, that was close.
Nice!
He's blowing me!
Ow!
Oh my gosh, I almost died.
Love my greedy Yoshi ghost.
Okay.
We have to get to the whale.
I can use the green box again.
Vendor!
Thank you for 6 months.
Oh my gosh.
I saw those guys.
Okay.
This thing needs more air in it.
It's not very taut.
Hey!
We got all three.
Missed the puzzle piece?
No I didn't.
Oh shoot.
Oh please!
Please!
What the...
What got me?
I think it was the...
Look at how cute they are, little bumblebees.
They're cute as little bumblebees though.
Alright, we still have one guy...
that we can still get.
Oh, that's a lot of money.
I got greedy.
I once again...
have been greedy.
Really cute.
Thank you.
Wait a second.
Ayami Mama's art is cute.
Okay, money.
Money.
Oh man, missed the money.
It's okay.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, there's a guy over there!
I
didn't go for the money, I'm just...
You know.
Hot dog.
Yeah, hot dog.
Oh gosh.
I can't see.
Am I in the right spot?
That was close.
That was really close.
Okay.
Nice.
I think...I don't know if I can...
Oh I can, I think.
Oh shoot.
Please!
Alright, so we've gotten all the guys at least.
There's still a warp?
I wonder if it's anywhere around these edges.
Alright, underplayed.
Thanks for the hat.
Oh my brother.
Thanks for the hot dog.
One second.
Hold on brother.
Stop.
3.0 Ray W is wild.
Congrats again on that.
Thank you.
I honestly was like so shocked at how...
Many people like...
Oh there's a guy right there!
Oh god, I didn't even get the thing.
What is this cruel?
What is...This is a cruel mistress.
I didn't even want to go on the boat.
Spooky level.
Spooky time!
I really...Before the debut I was like...
Kind of wracking my brain about it.
I was like, I feel like I have not enough at all.
I feel like I have not enough at all.
I was seriously like...
I need to have something else.
There was like just one...
Something else that I wanted more.
But I'm glad that people liked it still regardless.
Even the moon is spooky.
Oh no.
Wait, what do these guys do again?
Why are you staring at me like that?
We loved him.
I'm happy about that then.
Oh
come on, what a jerk.
Wait, what the hell?
He moves out of the way.
This guy is such a jerk.
It's already...It's not enough that I have to be in this shit fountain?
And then you are also gonna be such an ass to me?
Come on!
Let that serve as a reminder that we are always behind you.
Thank you.
Why can't I...I'm in a literal fountain of shit and I can't...
This bird sucks.
Look, he is staring at me like...
Are you trying to get that?
How do I get this?
Is there anything else?
This guy sucks.
Oh my god, I give up.
Maybe there is a power-up.
Maybe this?
Oh.
It's...
Oh, it's this one.
It's the slow down time thing.
Oh gosh.
I'm not very good at this one, I think.
I guess we are gonna get good.
Haha, to you.
Stupid.
Idiot.
Dummy jerk.
Too slow.
Are you telling us we have bad taste for getting excited about things you do?
I just have, I think, very high expectations.
So...
In my brain, I'm just like...
It was not enough.
So I believe that to be so.
You know?
I have pretty high expectations.
How do I get that guy up there?
Oh my goodness.
Oh shoot.
Nice.
Got our first guy.
Those high expectations were exceeded?
I'm glad you think so.
Oh my god.
Get his butt.
I can't get him.
Come here.
Nice.
Alright.
These are so silly.
Nice.
I'm going to my mic instead of...
Like this mic instead of...
Instead of...
Instead of the mic on the...
Nice.
Kill him.
Who is this?
Alpha male.
Could do with some piano lessons.
What the hell are you?
What's over here?
Anything?
Anything over here?
No.
Nothing of value?
OK.
Why let me walk over here then?
Music is so fun.
Chris Redfield.
Sorry, I was just like who is that again?
Oh shoot.
OK.
I remember now.
Oh shoot.
I'm dead.
At least I got the...
At least I got the puzzle piece.
Shoot.
Guys, I didn't make it in time.
No!
This is like the perfect... You got to be perfectly timed.
I missed a thing over there.
No!
Really got to be looking over the edges more often.
Got to be thinking about... I got to be living on the edge.
I got to be like...
You know what?
I'm not going to deal with you guys.
In fact, you neither.
Take them out.
Who knew her greed had limits?
Doesn't really.
I'm ultimate greedy.
I'm super greedy.
I barely... I just... I barely tapped him.
Let's just go.
What's up there?
That makes me need to jump, huh?
Get him!
I give me to winner.
Thank you, Barbos.
Was that... Did I miss anybody?
Ok, no.
Good, good, good, good.
Good, good, good, good, good.
Anything up here?
Nice.
That's a... Wait.
I knew it was a trap.
He was jumping up and down.
But we did get the bubbles up here.
Yippee-ki-yay!
Any other things over here?
Anything over here?
Any hidden...
Any... No?
Ok.
Nice reflexes.
Thank you.
Oh, goodness.
Nice.
We are killing it, you guys.
Yippee-ki-yay.
Yippee-ki-yay, I'm in Phantom!
It's usually like... One of these.
Oh no!
Enjoy your recent 3.0.
Thank you!
With the collabs.
Yeah!
Lot of fun.
I'm glad you liked it.
Oh, big guy.
Lots of money.
Nice!
Nice, nice, nice.
Ok.
I hear someone laughing.
Oh.
Let's grab that.
Oh my goodness.
I thought I was gonna die.
Holy moly.
I thought his teeth was gonna be so long.
Oh, it's this thing again.
I remember doing this before.
And this way.
What's this way though?
Mysterious.
What is this?
That's scary.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, the lights go out.
Oh god.
Uh...
Ah!
What?
You can fall off!
You can fall off of it?
Ok.
Holy moly.
I have to stop the time...
When the lights are on...
So I don't fall off of the thing.
Ok.
What did I just... Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Hello.
Oh, it's another... Another Resident Evil.
Alpha Female.
The Master of Unlocking.
I don't know any other names though.
I feel terrible.
Chill.
And...
Oh shoot.
Was I too early?
We're good.
Throw!
Oh my gosh, I have to parkour...
Off of...
His throw up.
Why are you eating garbage?
Too early.
That was so close.
That was so...
Why are you eating garbage?
It's Jill Sandwich.
Oh I have to... Ok, this one is interesting.
Nice.
But don't... Why do I feel like I need to be inside there?
Oh my gosh.
Look at him go!
This poor little guy!
I got you!
I don't... I do have you!
Nevermind, we don't need to be in there unless there was a...
You think there was a puzzle piece?
We still have one more puzzle piece to get.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running!
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh gosh.
These ghosts are annoying.
You think I'll be knocked off the... Ok, maybe I'll be fine here.
Ok, nice.
Where could the last puzzle piece be?
I wonder if I missed it already.
Did I miss my chance?
Oops.
I think I saw it.
I see it, it's in the tornado.
Oh yeah, I see it too!
Good eye.
If I die, it's ok, it's worth it!
It was worth it!
Good eye guys, thank you.
Oh shoot.
Can you even get it with... I don't think so.
It was sideways, right?
Maybe here is the best... route!
Oh gosh, that was so close.
Wait, how do I... I have to smash it?
Yeah!
We did it!
Wasn't there a warp in here though?
Oh no, there wasn't.
100% baby.
Of course I would 100% the spooky place, of course I would.
Send my guys home.
How many do I have now?
195.
Oh my gosh, we're so close to the...
We're so close to the...
If I do this one, we'll be able to get the 200.
Wow!
Under the sea!
It's quiet.
Too quiet.
Who's breathing?
This guy?
Wake up.
Stop breathing like that, it's annoying me.
Doom, doom, doom, doom.
This is like the most underwater level sound ever.
Who's making that sound?
There's sounds everywhere.
Is there stuff above the water too?
Like what's over there, you know?
Oh see, there is stuff above the water.
We must be vigilant.
Gamers, we must look up for the first time in our lives and after lives.
Gamers, we gotta look up.
Oh my gosh, I almost didn't get that guy.
What do you need me to do?
Punch you in the face?
Stop being such a little bitch.
Thank you.
Penguin!
What does it do?
Nice!
Can I like speed jump?
Oh my god, I'm beautiful!
This level reminds me of Spyro so much.
Sorry bananas.
Little monkey.
You're not gonna catch anything with a banana.
No fish wants to eat a banana.
Kinda does.
This one reminds me of Spyro the most.
Because of the robotic fish and like the little guys.
I don't know why.
I mean, I know why, but like...
It just reminds me of Spyro, that's all.
That's all.
Not even a banana fish?
Not even a banana fish.
Oh my goodness.
I got all of those in one go.
I'm guessing we're gonna have to crash into you.
Holy moly.
Maybe... How do I defeat you?
Not like that!
I don't think we... I don't think we... I don't think we do that.
Oh my gosh.
This is not the easiest way to swim.
There we go.
Go, go, go!
Please,
I want the money.
Please, just give me the... OK, there we go.
It's making me dizzy here.
It's making me dizzy.
Did I get all of it?
No.
Let me try again.
I don't really like the swimming.
You know what?
Good enough.
Whatever, good enough!
Oh gosh.
I'm so bad at this.
Sorry.
Oh no!
I gotta kick him in the face.
Thank you!
Stop being sad.
Just go for a walk.
Punch you in the face.
I wish all my bullies punched me in the face.
I would have not been so sad.
I did not expect this to be what happened with the...
You know, like...
Hearing that epic chorus and then...
And then it just became...
It just became this chill track.
What happened?
So silly.
Nothing really?
Oh there is a puzzle piece.
How many puzzle pieces?
We haven't gotten anything you guys.
Am I...
I just realized we haven't gotten any guys.
Have I missed them or am I just...
Or are they all in here?
There is no way, right?
I didn't grow up with Spongebob and I always wondered...
Is the pink fat starfish the Krusty Krab?
What do you mean?
Is he the Krusty Krab?
No, this is Patrick.
They are all in here.
This is a really big level.
We gotta free our starfish friend.
What's up there?
Money.
Money in here.
Where are our friends?
At least it kind of mixes the...
What happens if I make it?
Ok, hold on.
Hold on, I'll do it too.
I can do this too.
Come on!
Jumping through hoops!
I got a trophy for it even.
Nice, let's go.
Let's try this guy out.
Let's just... I don't know why I chose this guy to be there first.
I don't know why.
This area is really big.
There is so much to go around in here.
Our second one.
I see, I see.
The first one, it must be surely that one being surrounded by the spikes.
Surely, surely, surely.
This area is huge!
There is a ship.
There is everything.
Oh my gosh, there is a guy stuck in here.
We'll get him, we'll get him.
It's our first guy, actually.
Free Patrick Star.
Let's get these guys down here because they are ruining my vibe.
Oh gosh.
Oi!
Yeah, you want some of this?
Too slow.
Oh my god, look at them run!
Dummies.
Oh wow, there is a lot going on in here, isn't there?
Alright, two...three...
and four.
Yes!
I think I have to enter from the top.
Hello!
Look, he waved at me.
He is waving at me.
Can I kill these guys?
Actually, I don't think I need to do anything with them.
They got their own...
They are handling things on their own.
I wonder if you can hit their goggles.
Maybe, but I don't want to try.
I don't want to try...
because I don't know where...
There hasn't been like a safe point, like a checkpoint, you know?
Take the money.
What's in here?
Oh...
Oh my gosh!
I got you!
I got him!
Number two!
I want to get these guys though.
I can't get low enough.
No one?
No survivors.
Oh my gosh.
No!
There are so many!
No survivors.
Holy moly!
There is so much going on in this level, huh?
Hi!
Hey!
Oh!
I'll never forgive you.
What's in here?
Bad guys!
Oh!
I destroyed another one!
Let's go.
He is getting happier.
Thank you for the friend!
Thank you!
Welcome back!
Look,
we are playing Astro Bot.
And it's very cute.
But these levels are killing me.
And I'm already dead.
Oh my god!
It was so close!
My reflexes.
My insane reflexes.
Yeah!
Oh, we gotta get this guy.
I just remembered him.
Raymagnix for the 515!
Gamer reflexes, everybody.
Don't you forget it.
Oh, sorry monkey.
I made him drop his...
I made him drop his fishing pole.
Sorry monkey.
What?
That should have counted.
Oh my god.
I'm never gonna get him at this rate.
Oh my gosh.
Ok, hold on.
He can wait.
When
did his last save?
No, we don't know.
I don't know.
Ok, that is gone.
Where did it last save?
Did I do this thing in here?
Let's check.
Oh, hello.
Yes, I think it counted.
I think.
Oh, is that a guy over there?
Please!
What the hell is this?
Secret octopus.
Nobody suspects a thing.
Who is this?
The guy in the platform?
Is he not on the platform?
Or is he back on the platform?
I kinda hate this level.
Oh.
All my homies hate water levels.
No matter the game.
Octodad.
I can't get that one.
I give up.
Definitely my least favorite level so far.
That's right.
And I gotta grab him and I gotta...
Wow!
Nice.
Hey, leave him alone!
Never trust water.
Oh no, he is still in the spaceship.
I see him over there.
Ok, good.
How many more guys do we have?
There is probably...
Ok, so we know where one is of those three.
And we need one more puzzle piece.
I'm surprised going through the hoop didn't give me a puzzle piece.
I'm sure there is a lot down there in the...
Don't look so sad.
You do the rest of the work.
Look, you can just slip your little arm out of there.
I did everything!
This is really relaxing.
Do you guys hear the water?
It's really relaxing actually.
Hold on, can I turn off the music?
Let's see.
My eyes are really starting to get bad with that headache.
It's nice though.
It's very relaxing.
Oh.
What the hell?
What am I doing these moves for?
Nice!
I do have a blue filter on the screen.
I do.
A blue light filter.
So, I don't think it's that.
I think it's...I'm honestly not quite sure.
Hopefully nothing serious.
Because it just kind of started like yesterday.
If I look around with my eyes in a certain way...
It just starts to hurt.
So I'm like...
Dang it!
My game time for the week is run out.
Truly.
No more game for me.
Time to stop being a gamer.
I've been game...I'm too much of a gamer.
Gamer too hard.
What's in here?
Oh, hello.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh gosh, you guys are fast.
I should be the final one.
Yippee!
Alright, but we still have much to do.
We still have much to do.
Yes.
Oh hello, who's this?
Just a guy.
Alright, so we know where the last normal guy is.
Our special guy is...Doko.
The music is so cute.
Slow-mo.
Let's beat this guy up.
Freak phantom gaming.
I'm a freak.
I'm a phantom.
I'm a freak phantom.
Oh no!
Kick this guy's butt.
Kick their butt.
Oh I hear someone.
Oh there he is.
Getting a little bit more used to the swimming.
Luckily.
Secret.
Cat-like companion.
A perfect partner to their Meowsternya.
Wait, is this the Monster Hunter cat?
Is it?
Secret.
How do I get out of this guy?
Do I tickle his uvula?
Tickle, tickle.
Let me out.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, I almost missed that.
Crazy.
Alright, now we just gotta get that one last guy and we're good to go.
Just gotta get that one guy from the alien.
And we are G2G.
Have you tried using the penguin not in the water?
Yeah, he just flaps his little flippers around.
Watch, watch, I'll show you.
Watch him.
He's so cute.
Just like that.
This part seems near impossible though.
He was looking for me.
I could have caught him off guard.
Maybe I need to sneak up behind him.
See, he doesn't notice me.
Sorry for the weird camera angle.
It's like pulling it, you know?
So...
My days of Metal Gear has touched me.
Get stupid.
Kinda want this money here since it just keeps showing up, but...
Let's grab the money.
Sorry, I don't mean to tickle your tummy.
There we go.
I just want the money.
Alright.
Upwards!
Hold on.
One moment please.
Everybody is clapping for me.
Everybody clapped.
Seven guys.
Yippee!
And we have so much money!
Good job guys.
So us, we are so good at this game.
We are so good at this game.
Did Octodad floss?
He might've.
Welcome to Astro Bot.
Where your favorite character will inevitably floss.
And you'll just lose years off of your life because of it.
Yay!
It's definitely something to behold.
Alright, everybody to your work.
Let's get some more gacha.
Oh, this is Safari Zone.
Here we go.
More gacha!
But snake flossing was great.
I think great is a heavy word.
Enchanted paintbrush?
Who is this?
I think you guys probably said it before, but...
Transforms concrete into a canvas.
Is it like Life is Strange or something?
Dovenki?
What?
This weapon is such a drag.
That's quite the line to use.
For...
That's quite the line to use, huh?
Given, given...
Sort of what it...
It's from PT.
You know, but...
When you know who the dad was, you're just kind of like...
Cute!
Okay, next.
Doggy toys!
Oh my god, cute.
Irresistible to robotic dogs.
Well, he's not doing anything with it.
Okay, do something.
If it's irresistible to the dog, why doesn't he play with it?
Controller skin?
Working.
Not a lilac.
Skin?
Outfit?
Golden outfit.
It's really pretty.
Five more?
Wind generator.
Cute!
Brr.
Grateful calf.
Didn't it say friend of the elephant?
Outfit?
Last one.
Oh, for medieval!
Medieval!
Yippee!
You know what?
That's good.
That's a good one to end on.
Let's go see what Pyramid Head does.
Yeah, we do have 200 guys, so we'll go back to that one area.
Okay, let's go see Pyramid Head.
Are you okay?
Are you okay Pyramid Head?
These guys are so cute.
It was over here, right?
Bing, bong, bong, bong, bing.
Was there any other ones I wonder?
I can't remember.
I feel like we have to...
Oh gosh!
I wonder if I should go back to some of the other areas and see if there were ones that I missed because I didn't have enough people.
This one we can do now!
I don't understand what's going to happen though.
Oh, we are lifting.
Holy moly, look at all these guys!
It's a cake.
Excuse me.
Sorry.
Wait, it's actually a cake.
Excuse me.
What is this?
What
the fuck is this?
Leapin' Lipin', a true 3D platforming pioneer.
He just stood there.
It was so anticlimactic.
He didn't even do anything.
He just was like, yeah, I'm a little guy.
Alright, let's go to the other areas.
Is there anything...
Oh, welcome back everybody.
I guess we haven't gone to this area over here.
Not sure how to get there quite yet.
Hey dogs!
Do something!
You want the ball?
Get the ball.
Get the ball!
These dogs suck.
No real prize for the bots we found along the way.
Yeah, I suppose so, huh?
The dogs don't do anything.
Okay, so we still need to go in there.
I think I've gotten everything here.
Oh wait, maybe not.
Oh, this is the thing we're trying to fix.
Interesting.
Alright, let's go look in the other areas real quick just in case.
And then we'll go back.
25 guys, please!
Up dog.
What's up dog?
Gray fox!
Gray fox, you came!
Psycho mantis, you came!
Who am I walking on here?
Raiden!
Wait!
Raiden and...
And...and...the boss.
Oh my gosh!
Everybody is here!
Hi Snake!
Hi Ace Combat!
Hi Dante!
Everybody is here.
All the goats are here.
Wait, there is a puzzle piece I haven't gotten.
You guys!
I did need to come back here.
We needed a hundred guys!
We did have to come back here.
Give my back!
We need three more.
Hurry up!
We need one more.
Who is not pulling their weight?
Nice.
Hey!
One guy.
Dante is so happy.
Sorry.
I didn't mean to shove him that far.
OK.
Let's go check the other area too.
This one over here.
Oh Raiden!
Wait, we haven't gotten Raiden's thing yet.
I just realized.
Stream until...Oh these are all normal guys.
It's kind of weird.
Stream until we get Raiden's item.
Have we gotten everything here?
Maybe we have.
I don't know.
I think we got stuff down there.
I remember down there.
Did we really get everything in here?
Seems like it.
Excuse me!
They are alive
still, right?
They made it, right?
Oh god!
I'm home now and saw...
I saw Idol Lives for the first time in Japan.
Yosugawa.
I got a Cheki with Chia and I get it now.
Yeah!
Welcome to the Idol Brain Rott.
Seymour, also welcome home!
Things were on.
Now I feel even more bad that you went and got the...
got the...the card...
while you were on your last day.
I'm sorry.
Oh my gosh, we almost...should we...
I really don't feel like searching for him, but it's a special character.
It's not a normie guy.
What do you guys think?
The guy is easy to find?
He is?
OK, I'm gonna...
Wait!
We can pay money, can't we?
To get the bird.
Do you think it's near the star?
Oh, I don't have enough money for the bird.
That's so pathetic.
Give me money, please.
Thank you.
The warp?
We are...
Alright.
There we go.
Towards the beginning, huh?
Towards the beginning...
Maybe?
If we can get the warp...
Oh wait, I think the warp was at the very end, was it not?
Cause I saw...remember there was the...
If you saw it, there was like a little guy...
with a handle on him at the very, very end.
So I wonder...
Leave me alone.
Warp is near the start as well?
No way!
Huh?
Wait, so what was that guy I saw at the end then?
Alright.
OK, I'm trusting you guys.
I'm trusting you guys.
Near the start...
Come here.
Now look around.
OK.
Where am I?
Guy is near the brother.
Near brother...OK.
Looking around.
Looking over the edges.
Grabbing money while on the way around.
Near brother.
Oh my god!
On top of his head!
Brother!
You couldn't tell me this!
Oh my gosh!
Is this a little granola?
Yay!
Alright.
Now where is the warp?
Granola?
Oh, whoops.
One, two, three!
Where's the warp?
Andrigos!
Thanks for the 20 gifts!
Thank you!
Thanks so much!
Check brother again?
Brother!
Are you still here?
Brother, come back!
Maybe if I deflate this, he'll be like...
What are you doing, idiot?
Brother!
Can I restore?
OK, let's restore.
He dipped out.
For real!
I got all those.
I still got to keep all the...
I didn't get to...Oh wait, unless...No.
I think I still got to keep all the money.
I think so.
I think.
Fly over to the bamboo pot.
Bamboo pot.
You keep the money.
Asuka.
Alright, brother!
Brother, I'm counting on you, brother!
Brother!
Brother.
OK.
Brother, don't leave yet.
Brother, brother, brother, brother.
Don't leave yet, brother.
Brother.
Brother, I've always wanted a brother.
I'm sorry.
I'm so annoying about...
No, no, no, no.
Alright, brother.
I'm checking you out.
What do you got going on?
Oh, you were holding out on us.
Brother!
It's not that over there, is it?
It's not that all the way over there, is it?
Brother, I need you to...
Check it out.
Here we go.
I don't get enough air.
How many secrets was he hiding?
He literally... We kind of just robbed him, but...
Oh, the ladybug!
The bounce of the bug.
Thanks for the superchat!
Are we just gonna ignore how Minto just swatted that little shit out of the sky?
Oh,
oh my goodness.
Chill out.
We were so... Wait, I think I need to get closer.
Okay, maybe like that.
Yes!
We did it everybody!
Someone said bamboo.
I was like, I don't think I've seen a bamboo.
I don't think I've seen a bamboo pot around here.
This is why.
Oh, I need to go...
Huh?
Oh.
Oh, sorry.
I think we're good.
Oh no!
It's okay.
I have a cord.
It's all good.
Wow, I just charged this too.
That's kind of crazy.
Oh, this is fun.
I don't like...
Nice!
Secret.
Yeah, this one was really good.
This one was kind of crazy.
Thanks for the help guys.
Controller!
Secret.
Danger dojo.
Do we want to go in right now?
I'm thinking maybe...
I want to beat the boss here.
Like maybe get this guy.
Beat this.
And then maybe...
Call it a day.
I really wanted to go long, but...
I took even some medicine, but...
Just since I'm feeling a little icky.
Oh no, not the square challenge.
Puzzle piece!
Got it.
You're no match for me.
Yes, sirree.
These ones though.
Are you going to turn into a thing?
Oh.
Not yet.
Just one guy here.
Let's dive on in to the boss.
It has already been four hours.
That's crazy.
I lose track of so much time in this game because it's so much fun.
Go, go, go!
Can I aim on a single guy?
Can I even get a single guy?
Thank you.
So mysterious here.
The flowers are luminescent.
Ok, we'll wait for this.
There we go.
Oh, it's a time stop again.
Look at his face.
Get got.
Get got, guys.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
Is this a JoJo's Bizarre Adventure reference?
Yeah, this is a JoJo's Bizarre Adventure reference.
They are the first to ever do time stuff, you know.
No, never done before.
Time stop, time slow has never been done before.
I feel so attacked.
Oh, wait.
Why can't I jump on top of that?
I want to light it up.
That's strange.
Oh my god!
Oh, is that a Toho reference?
Yes.
Toho Project.
Never been done before.
Let me check the sides.
Fangirl Castle!
Thank you so much.
Welcome to membership.
Let's take a little shower, you stanky.
Don't you feel better?
Don't you feel more refreshed after taking that shower?
Oh my god.
I almost went through it myself.
How do we light that one though?
I feel like it's a secret.
Doesn't it feel like a secret?
It's a secret.
Are there any...actually...
Oh, there's just a guy here.
Maybe not.
Maybe...like it feels like a secret, right?
No sickness will ever bring Lay Mintlow.
We will never relent.
We will never surrender.
Yes.
Thank you Barbies!
Bait the chameleon to shooting at it.
I think it would just be coins though.
I think.
I think we get the guys from...
From the boss.
From fighting.
Uh oh.
There's our hearts.
There's our...Oh, it's a giant chameleon!
Mecha Leon.
Oh gosh.
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, ouchie ouch.
I gotta go up and I gotta pull his tongue!
Oh, he's purple now.
What's going on?
What was that sound?
Oh, I think he's gonna shoot another...
Okay.
Oh my god.
Okay, we made it.
No!
Oh, come on.
That was so...
That was so rude.
We gotta get rid of the chameleons first.
And I can't see these guys.
Did I really die?
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Whatever.
Wait a second.
Three chameleons this time?
Excuse me?
Can I jump on his tongue?
Right here?
No, I cannot.
Now I can.
Close, close, close.
Beat him up!
Tall, but with...
But with slowdown would be awesome.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Now do it again!
It's actually a nice easy mode.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
I can grab this guy at least.
Nice.
We're gaming?
Wait.
Okay.
So unfair!
Dang it.
Almost there, I think.
I don't know if I can get them.
Okay.
No!
No way!
Come on!
I have to be good here.
I have to just be good.
Oh my gosh.
Oh shit!
I didn't realize what he was doing.
I thought the things were gonna drop.
I thought the things were gonna drop to have the little enemies.
This is what I thought he was about to do.
Okay.
A one.
A two.
A three.
Okay.
Wait, let me restart.
Wait, will it restart the whole level?
Okay, nevermind.
Oh.
Oh goodness.
Run, run, run!
I wanted to get to at least second phase with no death or... Yeah.
With full lives, you know?
Oh well.
You got this.
Thank you!
Oh shit!
Oh my god.
I slowed down though!
I did.
I ruined the run.
I ruined the run, everybody.
I only have one life left.
Okay.
Come on.
We got this.
This guy is not so bad.
It's just me being silly, I think.
It's just my silliness.
Oh wait.
I'm gonna do this.
And then this.
Like that.
There we go.
Run, run, run!
Hit, hit, hit, hit, hit, hit, hit!
Punch, punch, punch, punch, punch, punch!
Alright.
Alright, I'm gonna go on the second time.
There, there, there, there, there.
Go.
Two.
Three.
And we're here.
Alright.
I don't know actually how I'm dodging this.
Okay.
Somehow, we did it.
We can take out this guy.
Let more guys drop.
Take out this guy.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run!
Take out this guy!
Got him.
I don't exactly know how to dodge this thing, but...
I just kind of run in circles until...
Oh gosh, wait.
I think I ran right into it.
That's my bad.
I think I... I think I ran around so much that I ran right into it.
Bottom.
Right here.
Oh, I think I got hit, so I wasn't able to see the whole thing.
You're slowing too early on the missiles.
Oh, I think that's probably it, huh?
Aiya!
Okay, don't fall here.
Okay.
Okay, now here he's going to do the missiles.
Okay, on that side.
Oh my goodness.
Can I walk under here?
Okay.
And...
Oh shoot.
Oh no!
What's going on?
What are you doing?
I didn't see him.
Oh my...
He cheated?
Yeah.
You're getting closer now.
Yeah, I think that's the last part, so we just gotta... just gotta get it, you know?
Oh no.
That was so close.
Is that about the timing, maybe?
Yeah, I think so.
Oh, whoops.
We have
to have them, like, hold on me, and then I...
This guy's, like, right on the edge.
Okay.
I have to have them hold on me, and then I can do it.
And then I can run.
Yeah, like that, I think.
Oh my gosh!
That was way too close!
Okay.
Easy does it, easy does it.
There we go.
Okay.
Nice, nice, nice.
Alright.
That one felt close.
Now we know he's gonna do it all on that side.
Oh, nevermind!
What?
That still got me?
No way!
That's so rude!
I guess it's whatever side I'm on.
Ultra!
Come on!
This guy sucks so much!
Is this... Is there any other guys?
I can't tell.
This might be it.
Ultra!
Oh,
there we go.
What am I doing with him?
Nice.
That one hurt.
That was really brutal.
We got...
We have a literal bean.
Bye-bye!
What?
I'm playing soccer with the bean.
Bye-bye!
Nice.
What is it?
Loco-roco?
Loco-roco.
I think I've heard of it before.
We go to the loco-roco-loco-moco-loco world.
Now that is what you get with a grit as iron as yours.
Thank you.
Look at that.
We have 100% in all these worlds even.
Loco-roco world.
Going loco.
Let's do it.
Let's beat this galaxy.
You will feel joy from this place.
I already feel good.
I hope he doesn't get kidnapped.
You stay right there mister.
We are connected.
We are connected by our strings.
I became one!
We fused!
I have to tilt it?
Oh my god, no way.
Come on!
There we go.
Goodness gracious.
Oh my gosh, it's a heart!
The music is too cute.
OK, we made it.
Is there anything in the tree?
I guess we'll never know.
Watch out for the spikies!
Grab him!
What the hell is happening?
Speedy blob.
Can he sing?
Yes he can.
Tante!
Money.
Squeeze!
Oh no!
Hold on.
We will squeeze in here.
Everybody!
There we go.
Together!
Back together!
Nice!
OK.
Back together!
Oh my goodness.
I missed him.
Hold on.
Is there anything in the trees?
I'm speeding.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Money!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Wait!
Money!
OK, I got it.
How do I get up there?
I did it!
Exuberant blob.
The big fan of rigor.
I feel like this game, this one in particular, this level in particular is bringing out my inner child.
Stylish blob.
Her voice has a certain je ne sais quoi.
What does it mean?
What the?
Hold on.
I can't get the money!
One more.
Hold on.
I'll wait.
Launch me!
Oh my gosh.
We almost did not make that you guys.
Grab that money.
Everybody...
I see him over there.
Watch out.
We got the voracious blob.
Deep voice.
Bottomless stomach.
I got it.
Give me a second.
Is this how this game plays?
Give me this.
I see another one.
Hold on.
Stop playing.
Bumper with me.
Oh my god.
Please.
There we go.
Stop playing.
Oh my god.
I just want to get this tree over here.
Please!
It didn't do anything.
Do I need to roll into this?
OK.
Hold on.
Do I bounce into it?
I can't tell what I'm supposed to do here.
I'm supposed to be small.
Duh.
I just realized.
Get the money everybody.
Get the money.
Everybody grab a dollar.
Everybody grab a coin.
Oh my god.
Wait.
There is one more.
Thank you.
A funky force of nature.
Oh my god.
As we were standing here we got all the money too.
That's amazing.
Money.
Nice.
We missed one.
So close.
That was so fun!
Mothership's cooling fan.
When it spins, prepare to be blown away.
Get into my vagina.
That was such a fun level.
Oh my gosh.
This game never stops impressing me.
How much I feel like was thought of in this game.
That was so silly and the song was so cute.
I loved it.
It was so much fun.
Do I need to blow this?
Maybe not.
I need to dump it out.
Get out of there!
I think we did it.
Squeeze!
It takes two has a similar vibe variety in gameplay.
Yeah, I have seen it takes two before.
Oh super.
Oh dump it in.
Sorry.
Don't drink the coolant everybody.
Don't drink the coolant.
Oh, but it looks really delicious.
Wait, it looks kind of jelly.
Wait, it's my favorite thing!
Freezing taste.
Thank you garbage man.
Feels so cool.
Feels so good.
And into the hole.
Freeza!
I love the clapping.
Keep it cool.
It's me, I'm back.
I can't believe these count as little bots.
Are we building a PC?
No, we are building a PS5.
All is well.
Another guy is crashing!
Time to finally go here.
I see a snake.
Hi snake.
Hi Raiden.
Where is the other snake?
Pyramid head?
Snake!
Oh you are here.
Oh you are worrying me.
You are worrying me.
I thought you didn't love me anymore.
Even Psycho Mantis is here.
Alright everybody.
He is too sneaky.
Egypt you place.
Exciting.
End position everybody.
Where is the last three people?
Someone is not pulling their weight.
Do I go down?
Oh gosh you guys.
Don't drop me.
We are alright.
Alright everybody.
They magically got here.
Wait, let me in too.
Let me in too.
Ok,
that's how we get home.
Alright everybody.
Be on standby.
How did you get in here?
How long have you been here?
You are probably starving.
120?
That wasn't a very good whistle.
Sorry guys.
Schwarzer, thanks for five months.
Oh my gosh there are more guys up there.
Three whole guys.
Hold.
How
many more guys?
Here?
What are we doing?
Let me in.
What
about over here everybody?
We are not done?
100 guys?
We are getting everything done here.
Holy moly.
Oh me too?
I'll go in.
Oh my god we are...
Oh gosh.
Nice.
Alright everybody get out.
They are just all chilling there.
This game is so funny.
Can I get this guy?
I almost had his butt.
I got him.
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
Are we the baddies?
I mean we did kind of just take over this planet.
Like these things lived here before us and we just kind of took it over.
Alright, four guys.
Come on.
Where are you?
Someone is not pulling their weight.
Easy.
Wow!
Defendership.
There is more.
There is much more we must do.
They are all just watching me in such awe and admiring me.
My beautiful parkour skills.
They are like, wow!
Mito amazing!
Wow the most cool ever!
250!
I'm 50!
Ok.
I know your game.
I see your game.
Oh gosh.
Wow Mito amazing!
Mito has such strong powers.
Ok we can do this one.
What's this one over here?
Why don't I just take the ladder?
What are you guys doing?
Oh we push.
Now I...oh nice.
Oh I thought I needed to beat them up to join my party.
Sorry.
I just smacked their asses for no reason.
Or was there a reason?
I'm just saying.
Do you need a reason to smack ass?
Of course not.
Come on!
Hello.
Oh god.
Nobody is dead right?
Everybody is alive?
Don't fall in the lava please.
Ouch!
Ok.
Don't fall in.
Ok it's time you guys.
Ok.
It's for...whoa!
Barrel muncher.
Sometimes does what it's told.
Can it get me out of here?
No.
Ok.
Hold on.
I'll wait.
There we go.
Smacking ass is how I made all my closest friends.
And my mortal enemies.
Oh I see.
Anybody else want to join me?
Ok they are all just down there.
Just let them chill I guess.
I think I've done all that I can for now.
We have 216.
Gosh.
We have less than 100 left guys.
I think we've done everything else in this area that we can for now though.
Are they starting to jump up?
Did you open the 200 one in the ice zone?
I did, yeah.
I did, I did.
Thank you though.
Press triangle to call...Oh I can?
I didn't realize.
Thank you though.
Our final universe to be called upon is...
The bird universe.
The bird zone.
Feather cluster.
I really feel like I could finish today.
Ok.
Oh my gosh!
You rude!
Rude, rude alien!
Oh there is a lot in here.
How much did the last one have?
Oh, just as many.
It's hard to think about that because it feels so fast sometimes.
I think I'll save it for one last stream.
I think I'll save it for one...
last stream.
A couple more hours to go.
Yeah, it feels like that, right?
And I don't necessarily want to 100% it, but I do want to get like...
Like, because I...It depends on how I feel to get all the challenge levels, you know?
But I do want to at least get all the puzzle pieces from each thing.
And we still are missing a few from the older levels.
Gacha time!
Wait, how much money do I have?
How much money do I got?
Oh yeah, I do want to do the secret warp levels.
Let's do that one that I just unlocked, right?
That one warp level that I just unlocked.
Actually, let's do that.
Sorry.
Let's do that and then we'll do the gacha, because...
I'll get more money, you know?
Damien, thank you!
Thanks for the super chat!
How is your new model so cute?
I love it.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
We'll do this one.
Danger dojo.
And then we can do a gacha.
There really is danger dojo.
Is my ship OK?
My ship.
The music is awesome though.
A little caterpillar.
Sorry.
Oh my God, I'm running up walls.
I'm a real ninja.
I see him over there.
I see you.
Oh my gosh.
Let go of my friend.
Nice.
And money.
Nobody saw that.
Nobody saw that either.
Nobody saw that either, OK?
Yeah, we're good.
Don't worry about it.
Is there anything up there, you think?
Maybe not.
Yeah, you saw nothing.
Oh.
Goodbye lamp.
Volcano.
Oh, it's this part.
I have to be able to get him.
So do I like create my own platform?
Maybe this one needs to be a bit lower.
You think it's too low?
Let's see.
Oh my gosh.
No!
I hear you!
Hold on!
Oh my God.
I have to get that guy first.
Oh wait.
Uh-oh.
I made it somehow.
I think I did a good job, you guys.
I think I did it.
Nice.
I'm pretty good at that.
I was talking with the team who did Freak or Treat with me.
And we were thinking of...
Get out of here.
Of doing like seasonal updates.
Maybe even making a way to have...
For people to be able to make their own levels.
But that is still not confirmed.
But we'll probably do seasonal updates and stuff.
Just a little bit at least.
Not a ton probably, but...
Yeah.
Oh, one more guy.
How did I do the flower?
Oh yeah, that's right.
Monkey!
Get off this.
This is my monkey.
This is my platform monkey.
So yeah.
It was funny because he was just like...
You know, it would be really fun to do this.
We know you already spent a lot of money on it.
I was like...
But it was so much fun making it.
I didn't do so much, you know, obviously.
I'm not a game developer, but...
Just like, being part of the planning and everything was so much fun.
A few days late.
Grats on the new model.
Thank you!
Oh my god.
Ambush!
Wait, I wanted to check that room out.
There were some more people I wanted to include, but they didn't...
Like, one of the people didn't respond to me until literally yesterday.
So, I was like, okay, well...
In the update, I can fit you in probably.
Western warrior.
A pirate and a samurai?
Deadly.
Yeah, I didn't want to include anybody as an NPC.
Unless I, you know, got their explicit permission.
But also, I needed the...
I wanted the voice...
Oh my gosh.
I wanted the voice clips for it, so...
The voice lines.
What are these ones from?
Oh, Neo!
Vengeful spirit.
It's me!
A samurai no more.
Freakin' watch will become the second most popular portable guide, so...
I'm sure it will.
I'm messing up there.
Their zen garden.
This level is so cool.
Wait, where do I go?
Shoot.
That was
close.
Nice.
Freak or treat was incredibly fun.
Whether you update it or not, I want to say thank you for it.
It was my...
It was...
Wait, it was all my fun on my first day off in almost a month.
Bless.
I'm really happy to hear that.
Platform.
Again.
OK, that should be...
Maybe good?
Don't like that.
I really like trick or treat beat as a kid, so this version is pretty nostalgic.
Me too!
It was one of my favorite online games to play as a kid.
So I really...
Wanted to bring it...
Back.
Nice.
First try, baby.
I really wanted to...
Bring it...
Back.
Whoa!
But wait, wait, wait.
What was over there?
Hold on, hold on.
I saw this.
This one.
Oh, this one.
Oh my gosh!
Money!
Are you OK being in a game and us using the sounds you make on stream before the game?
Is this a real proposition?
Or like a real question?
Or are you just...
I mean, yeah, of course I'm OK with that.
But I'm also nervous.
But I'm also...
Scared of what you'll make.
What do you mean what sounds I make?
OK, that should be good.
Oh wait, I'm losing some of them!
Oh, shoot.
Got it.
Wait, I'm too good at the game.
Ever stop and wonder about the construction process of video game castles and dungeons and stuff from the in-game universe point of view?
Yeah, I do actually.
Demon swordsman!
Took up the gauntlet against a demon army.
Wait.
I think I need to do this again.
That should be good.
Probably.
Easy game.
Easy game, easy game, easy game.
Did I get everything?
Easy game.
Oh
my gosh, guys!
I'm a ninja.
With a smoothie.
Say cheese!
Oh, now we get money for... Oh my gosh.
They're hunting me!
I destroyed it!
I destroyed their hunt on me.
Sorry, guys.
Tamago.
I'll take it.
Actually, I really want sushi now.
Wait.
No!
Oh my gosh, this is kind of weird.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
My aim...
My depth perception is...
First try.
Guys, it's an easy game.
Easy game.
Idiot sandwich.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
I
could have gotten the big money.
My bad.
I could have gotten the big money.
Secret!
Don't...
Don't worry about it.
Alright, gacha time.
Hello, welcome to the army!
We need 30 more.
We're making like a big statue?
Use this 7 month memble flex for gacha luck.
They're cool!
7 months!
Let's go.
What do we want?
Oh my gosh, there's a soda can right at the bottom.
Okay, we want...
There was something else I think I wanted.
12 months for flex for luck.
Let's go!
Oh yes, Raiden's item.
Raiden and if there's a snake outfit.
A bo staff.
Okay.
I'm gonna fucking become the Joker.
Evidence collectors.
Who is this?
Looks like Maddie.
I just got sushi for the first time.
Was a little sad because it arrived hot.
But it's okay, I microwaved it for a minute before eating.
Wait, what?
Fukura, thanks for the gift!
Explosive cask.
Make monsters go boom!
Outfit?
Outfit!
I can become gross?
Star creator, thanks for the gift!
Wait, stealth outfit?
This isn't the stealth outfit I wanted!
This game is making a mockery of me.
This game is making a mockery of me!
Close enough.
We have to put it on though.
It's a stealth outfit, we gotta put it on, I guess.
We have stealth outfit at home.
It would be awesome if it actually made me hard to see by enemies and all.
This one looks freaky.
What is it?
Last of Us, right?
Eww, I'm so nasty!
This game is a joke.
Am I a joke to you game?
Am I a joke to you?
We couldn't even get Raiden's thing.
Didn't I say stream until we get Raiden's item?
Raiden, give me money!
I need more money, Raiden!
Well, we got Raiden today.
I gamed for him.
I gamed quite hard actually.
That was said.
We got Raiden at least.
What is this thing?
Oh, he goes to another location.
That's so fun.
Where's that minks for the coin?
Thank you.
Our place is so lively.
There's so many guys here.
We still have 50 left.
Mushrooms are good and they love you.
I hate mushrooms.
Mushrooms ick.
What is this?
What the hell?
Who left the bathtub here?
Oh, it's for me.
What
is going on?
That's gross.
That guy was peeping on me in the bath.
Is he going to kick my ass?
Wait, let's see if he does it again.
He kicked my ass.
Well guys...
Oh, what's here?
Why is this so magical?
Oh, these are the flowers!
These are the flowers I got.
That's right.
Is that me?
Wait.
You can make infinite people.
Make more little guys.
Make them join the army.
That is your duty.
That was terrifying.
What a nightmare.
Guys, this is fun.
I did think...
I did think maybe I would try to complete it today, but you know what?
We'll just go for next time.
I almost want to do some of the...
Hold on, let me finish my thought.
Let me finish my thought.
What?
I almost...
I want to do some of the puzzles off stream.
Maybe the puzzles of the worlds that I've gone to before.
Maybe.
Love the new model.
Thank you!
So, I might do... There's like, what?
Two or three puzzles?
That I could do off stream probably.
It's just the puzzle pieces, so...
For future animators, please have a room of a lot of Minto so we can laugh like an Osanai.
Lambda!
Thank you for the Akasupa!
I don't even know how much this is, but there's a lot of zeros.
Big Boss by Beloved.
I wish Konami do Metal Gear collab with gacha anime games.
I really need to see one of the snake to be in gacha anime game.
Please, just one gacha game is okay, Konami.
Please, Konami, I need this.
My gacha game is kind of snake-less.
I live with Ocelot.
I want to help him out.
So true.
What do you mean you live with Ocelot?
What do you mean by that?
Actually, that's so real.
Look at me.
I'm sleeping in front of Snake.
I'm such a freak.
Why am I sleeping in front of him?
This game is such a treasure.
This game is my treasure.
Gosh, I'm so glad I got into Metal Gear so I could appreciate all five of these little characters in here.
I'm so glad that they gave Metal Gear 5 characters, you know, despite it being such an old series.
Like, they still... There's like series in here that are, you know, I guess more beloved.
And they only have a few characters, but Metal Gear has five characters.
Any chance of Metal Gear Online 3 before you reach MGSV?
Well, I would have to get a server.
Or like, you know, for it.
If anyone wants to explain how I can, I would love to do that.
MGS4, Snake and Nike.
OK.
Yeah, I'm so... Oh no!
Oh no!
Wait, we gotta save her.
Oh my god, I don't think that's saving her.
Wait, I think we just killed Lara Croft.
Oh my god, he attacks her.
Oh no, I think he likes her.
Lev, no, please!
I don't know how much this is scaring me.
Hey Minto, can you pray to our lord and save your big boss so I can safely bring home my anime Umineko pachislot machine to Indonesia?
I'm going to buy MGS3 pachislot if someone sells it with the right condition.
Next if this succeeds.
Thank you very much.
This means a lot to me.
I'm praying for you.
Please let the pachislot get home.
Ow, I bit my tongue.
Hold on.
Get home safely!
Well guys, probably I guess the next week will be the final.
Oh, maybe next week.
Maybe the week after.
Might be once I'm back from...
from...
Great job getting rided!
Also, I can't get over how minty fresh you look now.
Thank you!
Do we get stummy on the next outfit?
I don't know.
You'll just have to wait.
We'll find out.
I will see you guys...
Tomorrow?
Yes, tomorrow.
I have to make my schedule still.
I will be gone a couple days next week.
Because like I said, I'm going to meet with Deoki.
So we can practice for our Atlanta concert.
I don't know what my stream stuff will be.
Entirely.
Of the following week.
But yeah.
Thanks for the fun stream!
Thanks Akane!
Thank you!
Thank you guys!
And I will see you tomorrow probably.
Bye bye!
Bye bye, bye bye, bye bye, bye bye...
Bye bye...
See you guys.
Thank you!
Goodbye!
Bye bye!